all right Mike I'm trying to keep still
but it's not it's just stay calm stay
calm all right all right I'm going to
talk about the Panic paper which has
been making the news a little bit
recently largely because it's been
completely misinterpreted let me show
you the paper here it is one of the
reasons I talk about it is that Leonardo
Ferreira is one of our PhD students in
the group here so it's kind of work
that's being done here Chris consolees
was work worked here until fairly
recently before moving to Manchester so
this is observations with James Webb
Space Telescope so it's really hot off
the press observations and in fact this
is a paper that came out in July so they
were really set and ready to go as soon
as the data started appearing they
started writing this paper it's been
grossly misinterpreted as somehow
changing the Paradigm of the Big Bang or
making it appear that cosmology is has
to be completely different from what we
thought it was it doesn't do any of
those things so the confusion is that
various people didn't get past the first
word of the title which is panic
exclamation mark That's because this is
one of these things that astronomers do
from time to time and presumably other
disciplines do as well which is to make
a joke in the title of their paper and
if you read on a bit it actually says
Panic act the discs which is a joke
about you know Panic at the Disco and
the band of that name another thing
about astronomers is they're like bad
jokes but it's a very bad joke it really
is and of course uh Panic at the Disco
actually has an exclamation mark after
the Panic which is why they also have an
exclamation mark it was a joke okay it's
been grossly over interpreted by various
people always implying that we're in a
state of panic by this uh result that
these people have found we're not but
it's just an interesting result surely a
title like that would get sanitized for
publication it might well do and this
paper hasn't been published yet so I
haven't yet seen the what the title is
going to end up being this is the
pre-print version so this is the version
that they just put out for people to
read before it's accepted for
publication is it rash to even let
people release these papers before
they've been peer-reviewed because not
only might the title be changed the
whole guts of the argument might be
changed it's what is the endless
argument about this some people take the
view that actually that you should put
papers out as early as you can because
that way you can kind of Garner feedback
on the paper which actually improves the
final paper by kind of a process of of
communication with the community by
putting it out there and so you can kind
of get feedback and improve your paper
the other pressure here is this is jwst
the whole world is working on this data
so if you don't put your paper out as
soon as you've got it somebody else will
get the result before you do so there's
a lot of sort of time pressure to get
your paper out in this particular case
tell me about this one what's caused the
problem okay so what they were doing is
they were just looking at some of the
early images from jwst and this is an
image of a cluster but they weren't
actually interested in the cluster they
were interested in the fact that
whenever you take a picture with jwst
there's a whole bunch of stuff in the
background and in particular they were
interested in the distant galaxies
because obviously when you're looking at
distant galaxies because of the finite
speed of light you're seeing them as
they were further and further into the
past as you look further and further
away and again it's hard how do you pick
out distant galaxies you kind of use the
properties of the amount of light that
you get in different wave bands to tell
you okay so this is probably a Galaxy
that's you know this kind of distance
away or this kind of distance away this
kind of redshift because remember we
measure distances by how fast things are
running away from us and so they use
that to try and pick out a sample of
galaxies that were basically made so
we're seeing them as they were when the
universe was between about one and two
billion years old right so now it's 13
point something or other billion years
old so it's you know if we're seeing
galaxies as they were very early in the
lifetime of the universe and this isn't
the first time people have seen those
galaxies the Hubble Space Telescope
could actually pick out galaxies at
those kind of distances as well but the
prevailing view that we got from the
Hubble Space Telescope data is that
galaxies at those great distances away
so very early in the lifetime the
universe were very messy very chaotic
things with blobs all over the place
they didn't look nice and smooth they
didn't look nice and symmetric the way
that galaxies do in the nearby universe
that sort of made a bit of sense because
you know presumably things were kind of
chaotic back then things galaxies were
just forming so you wouldn't expect
things to have settled down to be quite
so well behaved as they are now so you
might expect things to be that bit more
of random in nature what they found is
that that's not what the jwst is finding
they're finding that actually most of
the galaxies even those in in their
infancy are actually quite well behaved
quite symmetric and they're almost all
well at least half of them are dislike
systems you know they've got this
ordered motion of a disc in them so not
only do they appear ordered but actually
probably the Motions within them are
quite ordered as well and that again was
not what we thought from the Hubble
Space Telescope data from the Hubble
Space Telescope data it looked like at
those kind of early epochs maybe five
percent of galaxies were in disks and
now they're finding actually 50 of these
Galaxies have dislike structure so
almost 10 times as many so it was a very
unexpected result hence the panic but
it's not you know it's not turning the
Big Bang upside down it's turning our
understanding of how galaxies form a bit
upside down but it's not revolutionizing
absolutely everything that does seem
significant to me that we used to think
that early galaxies were a bit chaotic
and turbulent but actually they're
pretty like they are now and there's a
reason why the Hubble Space Telescope
results are different and why jwst is
allowing us to learn things that we
couldn't learn before Hubble Space
Telescope worked primarily in the
optical that means for these very
different distant galaxies it was
observing what it was actually observing
was light that was emitted in the
ultraviolet which had got redshifted to
the optical by the time it got to that
wall Space Telescope the trouble with
ultraviolet light is it's all associated
with very energetic star formation and
those kinds of things Bright Young stars
that produce that ultraviolet light that
tends to happen in a very clumpy way
even in the nearby Universe you know the
most dramatic examples of star formation
tend to be in these big clumps and so
you would naturally expect a level of
clumpiness that's just due to the fact
that your early observations the Hubble
Space Telescope observations are just
picking out the ultraviolet light which
is picking out where star formation is
going on jwst because it works all the
way into the infrared then it can
actually pick out optical lights or
Optical light that's emitted there will
be shifted to the infrared by the time
it gets to us and so that the light
they're seeing is much more kind of the
bulk of the Galaxy so there isn't
actually a contradiction between the HST
results and the jwst results it's not
like they're seeing different galaxies
they're seeing the same galaxies it's
just that the new results are sort of
better behaved less dramatic Optical
light which means we can pick out the
discs in these things that we couldn't
before it feels like with these early
images we're getting from jwst everyone
is peering past what's in the foreground
and what they're supposed to be looking
at and trying to look look behind and
see see deeper that seems to be the
trend at the moment that's certainly
true but obviously you know there's a
whole bunch of other astronomers who are
looking at all the beautiful stuff in
the foreground as well right it's just
that the particular bunch of astronomers
I tend to interact with tend to be the
ones who are looking at the stuff that's
going
one last question then because you did
make that Doom and Gloom video saying
that so many things could go wrong how
do you feel about how well jwst is going
so I'm delighted that I was wrong I
really sincerely had serious doubts that
it was going to work but it has all
worked beautifully and that's brilliant
and all credit to all the engineers all
the scientists who dedicated decades and
Decades of their lives to making it
happen because you know it really
wouldn't have happened if they hadn't
put in all that hard work it's not going
to get smashed up by meteoroids now is
it not likely so there was this early
impact in one of the mirrors which was
kind of unexpectedly big and so it did
kind of knock a little divot out of one
of the mirrors and in fact they've been
able to see it's degraded the images a
bit because the mirror is no longer as
perfect as it was because it's now got
this little divot in it but even now the
quality of the images they're getting is
higher than the specification for the
telescope before launch so actually it's
you know it's degraded a tiny bit but
it's still better than it was actually
expected to be
would have basically spent their entire
careers working on this telescope so
actually if it doesn't work that's their
life work down the tubes right so not
surprisingly that's kind of you know
that makes people pretty nervous
secondly it's a really large sum of
money it's you know the total budget
obviously as as the thing's been delayed
more and more one of the things that
always goes with delays is costs go up
and up and it's going to cost ultimately
about 10 billion dollars